[SPEAKER_02]: Evening of the 2nd of Wealsun, Jude and Paul have been signaling, getting the sergeant of the garrison, the commander of the garrison, to signal to the southern guard tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, a dialogue starts out.
[SPEAKER_02]: After you sending the word, Jude and Karmirg, basically you get back.
[SPEAKER_02]: The name Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then you send back Jude and the signals start going back and forth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now the principalities have something very similar to Morse code where they can signal each other using these mirrors and there is a communication that comes up.
[SPEAKER_02]: You learn that the group of marines that landed on the southern docks
[SPEAKER_02]: Were confronted by troops of hobgoblins as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they had managed to take the wooden tower, that's the guard tower, but were kind of holed up in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: They killed several hobgoblins, but they had lost three men.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's 27 of them left.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, they were very, very concerned about making sure, well,
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, they saw the sahaugin destroy the ship, and they saw what happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do we learn that the ship was destroyed?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because we didn't see it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, they said the ship was overwhelmed and is basically sunk at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: They also are concerned about Paul Rivero and if he's still alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, he is a prince, so they wanted to make sure that he was okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: They noticed that he was marching down the docks, so they saw what happened with you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did they see us go into the barracks?
[SPEAKER_02]: They didn't see that.
[SPEAKER_02]: They didn't see you make it to the barracks, but they had hoped that that was the case.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now we're signaling from the barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they also had hoped that the barracks wasn't overrun.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: They were actually considering taking some scouts and scouting that area out.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, now that they know that
[SPEAKER_01]: You were there and that the barracks are in the hands of the principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, and I give them numbers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say like 100 friendlies plus 20 marines from the ship, Paul's, you know, we're safe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, so basically it turns out that there are 150 marines still on
[SPEAKER_02]: The base.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here, when we go in, it's 150 plus our 20?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and then 30 here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So 200.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we have 200.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we lost like friggin 200 marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the sahaugin, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then again, with the 20 marines alone, we were able to storm the beach in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah, but we also weren't fighting the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sahaugin are a whole different.
[SPEAKER_00]: True, but right now we just need to worry about the hoggob since this hoggob can't get on the land.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what they tell you, what the sergeant or the guy in command of the group tells you is that they're gonna keep the tower here, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because they're gonna warn off any ships that are sent from Monmurg to make sure
[SPEAKER_02]: That they're not attacked by the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can they signal Monmurg if that's the tower that was supposed to send the signal originally to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Could they send a message to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_02]: They say no, they can't.
[SPEAKER_02]: All they have is they have short-ranged arrows that they can shoot flares up into the air with.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they will shoot warnings off if they can do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, the brazier that they used for the signal fire was taken by the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they have no way to actually signal.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in fact, this is really the place that you would normally do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could assume that any of these other places...
[SPEAKER_02]: The lighthouses could possibly do it as well, but this is normally where...
[SPEAKER_01]: That signal would come.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their expectation should they be attacked by the Sahaugin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because that would be like them overwhelming the ship, other than they have some fortifications, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So I just signaled, prepare to repel.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they're going to hold it, repel sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_02]: They say absolutely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right now basically what they say, once we're off the beaches, they're not worried about sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that anything I know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I think last time we basically talked about it and you knew sahaugin could come up onto the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: They hated them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They liked the beach.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I was saying.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they can stay out of the water for up to four hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they're not gonna attack a barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not gonna attack a barracks, they're not gonna siege, you're not gonna do anything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, pretty much, if you're in a tower of fortification up on the cliffs, the sahaugin would be at a big disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does the commander of the barracks have any idea of hobgoblin forces them?
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll get to that in a second, because you're gonna do a roleplay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want you guys to think about this.
[SPEAKER_02]: What you also learn
[SPEAKER_02]: And obviously this message is from Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, Gouge says he's gonna make it to where you guys are.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he needs to talk to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because his mission is
[SPEAKER_02]: Related to your mission.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically, Gouge gets a signal sent to you saying, I'm coming.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm coming tonight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I should be there as soon as I can get a group of guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're bringing a group of guys to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to sneak back to the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: But expect us tonight.
[SPEAKER_02]: And from then on, we're going to have to figure out where we're going to go and what we're going to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so that is the communication that happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: If at any point where we're talking you want to send back another message, we can do that, but let's start.